me my guitar well I guess this [ __ ] sink
captain even drink
we met with for us Americans currently
living in Berlin all were surprised by
the results of their country's
presidential elections quite literally
very very scared for the future now I
started feeling sick to my stomach a
little dismayed disconcerted upset
nervous uncomfortable it's shocking
I think it's shocking it's it's a I did
not even picture it as a possibility a
journalist and writer
Sally McGrane has lived in Berlin for 13
years she's currently working on her
second spy thriller Odessa at dawn but
even she never imagined a scenario in
which Trump would become the president
I mean he's new and the degree to which
he is totally unprepared for this
position and the kinds of things that he
says and the you know and I I think that
he became a candidate was a shock that
he won is a complete shock Trump's a
child like he can't handle criticism and
if he gets into a situation where he
feels that his honor is being put the
question of whatever he he he lashes out
there's a high chance that he will rule
with an iron fist but instead of
clenching his fists Matteo Dineen
prefers to pick up a pen
he's an illustrator he draws monsters
but friendly ones because Dineen is an
optimist out of principle
I'm pretty good at finding the silver
lining in almost any situation because I
can't live in a depressed like sad state
the whole time so I need to find that
little bit of light and grab on to that
and I've just been wrapped just racking
my brain trying to find that little bit
of light and I haven't found it yet I
think that he's already changed America
quite a bit just in this election cycle
there is a level of acceptance of hate
speech that has never been there before
racism and being openly racist is now a
mainstream reality I expect a little
more negative American sentiment I was
here during the Bush years and it was
quite a lot of that during that time
Europeans did not like Bush and they
definitely were not shy about letting
Curtis Tim Peck has been playing in
Berlin's bars and clubs for years he
also busts on the streets of the German
capital while he's not pleased with the
election results he thinks they could
provoke positive change
that that's what people start to see
that the electoral college in the way
that it holds up the two-party system is
not a positive thing what a democracy
needs is several different parties as
many parties is that democracy needs at
that time for the needs of the people
that's it's it's a little upsetting to
see that these are the two choices that
so many Americans would not happy at all
with Daniel brunette is producing
artistic director of the English Theatre
Berlin in his work he deals with current
social and political issues he accused
his Trump of speaking before thinking
about the consequences of his words I
think the potential for international
incidents and misunderstandings has
greatly increased if any of this
silliness about leaving NATO or pulling
out of NAFTA or anything that actually
goes through I think people are going to
realize that there are huge shades of
gray and incredible levels of complexity
behind these things that you simply
cannot approach with such silly black
and white rhetoric you cannot single out
groups of people and make them the
scapegoats I mean this is just against
every principle that we have and it's
something that you know really affects
the lives of people that I love but at
the same time the way I felt after I had
a cup of coffee was world still here
it's still turning mad
guess I'd go out swing